up
severe floods hit australia for the
third time in six weeks is the country
ready for a changing climate
global emissions hit their highest
levels ever do we really still have time
to avert climate catastrophe
and the world record-winning sailor
cleaning the oceans of plastic
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
solutions
now we start today in australia where
rivers have burst their banks after
intense rainfall hundreds of sydney
residents were forced from their homes
today many for the second time in a
month the city's already received more
rainfall in 2022 than it does in a whole
year on average much of australia's east
coast has been hit by three separate
intense weather patterns in the past six
weeks and entire towns have been
submerged in floods nicole johnson
reports from sydney
rescue workers try to retrieve a man's
body after his van became stuck in
rising flood waters
another victim of an unprecedented
season of rain on australia's east coast
camden has been flooded three times in a
month
alex jen is exhausted from it
this time he lost his shed
and almost his life
the car was so fast so forceful
was about to knock me out and the only
thing i could grab was this
and this branch actually saved me i was
holding on to this
for my life
muddy water has swept through the
bowling club again
volunteers say they've never seen so
many floods in such a short period of
time
i have noticed that there's been a
change and in particular the last three
or four months we've had
incredible amounts of rainfall and
obviously it's led to what we witnessed
last night this morning
for the last three years australia has
been hit by extreme weather events
the northern new south wales town of
lismore has been underwater twice this
year
and weeks of rain in sydney has led to
flash floods in streets homes and
businesses
the nepean river broke its banks and
other major bridges in the city are
being closed
rain in sydney is starting to ease but
the river levels are set to rise as this
huge volume of water moves downstream
bringing with it the risk of more floods
and australia's science agency says
global warming is making severe floods
more likely
the country's prime minister scott
morrison admits australia has an
increasingly challenging environment
australia is becoming a harder country
to live in because of these natural
disasters
but gary goody doesn't agree
even after three floods in a month
do you blame this on climate change
uh look i'm a skeptic i'm sorry no i
don't
no i don't i think it's just a cycle
we go through these cycles the
polarizing issue of climate change in
australia will no doubt play a major
role in the upcoming federal election
nicole johnston
sky news
camden
the world's climate scientists earlier
this week warned that there's now only a
narrow chance of limiting global warming
to that crucial 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial levels in short the world
is burning too many fossil fuels and not
doing enough to slow emissions
well levels of methane in the atmosphere
reached record levels in 2021 that's
according to u.s government scientists
now the gas is less abundant than carbon
dioxide but it's more powerful and is
largely as a result of oil and gas
operations
meanwhile the concentration of carbon
dioxide remains the most important way
to measure atmospheric change and that
number is also rising fast now experts
say that it's likely to hit
420 parts per million this month now
that's not only a modern record
scientists say it's over four million
years since there was last that much co2
in the atmosphere
and this chart here gives more recent
historical context now co2 levels start
rising along with the industrial
revolution so this vertical line here is
around the year 900 when the burning of
fossil fuels created a new and warmer
world 1900 that that day there and after
that you can see that the graph takes
off
well joining me now to tell us more is
dr ella gilbert who was on the show
precisely a year ago when the carbon
dioxide levels
hit 417 parts per million to explain why
this all matters so ella welcome to you
so tell us first of all what's happening
here what do these charts tell us
well these charts give an idea of how
much carbon dioxide is actually in the
atmosphere and that's related to how
much
the biosphere so forests and plants etc
take up um but also of course related to
our human caused emissions of co2
and why should we worry about this why
is it a cause for concern
well we know that greenhouse gases like
co2 are causing or the primary cause of
climate change and that of course brings
with it increased temperatures it brings
with an increased
risk of extreme events intensified
wildfires flooding the exact sort of
events that we've been seeing that
hitting australia right now um it hits
the most vulnerable people hardest and
it comes with you know things like sea
level rise and the whole suite of
changes that we have associated with
climate change and countries around the
world
are committing to targets to reduce
their emissions to hit net zero if those
goals are met what would happen to these
graphs
well hopefully um the rate of increase
would start to slow down so instead of
it being a a steep upward climb it would
start to plateau a bit and then if we
managed to bring our kind of
negative emissions technologies online
that can be as low-tech as planting lots
of forest or as high-tech as uh
solutions such as direct air capture
then the curve would start to not just
flatten but also decline and that's what
we need to do to reach net zero where we
have any emissions of carbon dioxide
balanced by net removals of carbon
dioxide
dr ella gilbert thanks very much indeed
so let's get some of those other climate
news now and tower bridge was closed to
traffic this morning after climate
activists abseiled off the sides of the
london landmark to unfurl a huge banner
protesting the use of fossil fuels
according to the group the action took
place at the root source of fossil fuel
funding in the uk the city of london the
protest comes after eight days of
disruption at oil facilities by
extinction rebellion and the just stop
oil coalition
a
million pound investment package has
been announced to help support the
government's new energy strategy the
financial package includes 240 million
pounds to fund low carbon hydrogen
production projects and 5 million pounds
towards carbon capture and storage
the prime minister says the strategy is
a long-term plan focusing on nuclear
power offshore wind and hydrogen that
will undo the mistakes of the past
and a century-old shark found washed up
on a cornish beach died from meningitis
a post-mortem is found
while it's the first report of
meningitis in the species scientists
said it's too early to link the disease
to man-made stressors in the environment
such as ocean pollution
the female greenland shark found just
outside newland harbour in mid-march is
still considered juvenile by marine
biologists but the species able to live
up to 400 years
now last month 175 countries came
together in nairobi to agree a global
plastics treaty tackling the pollution
crisis along the materials whole supply
chain now one day perhaps it might have
an impact but for now the oceans are
swimming in the stuff in our latest
climate diary we meet one world record
holding sailor who's now working on
cleaning up the sea
i'm ivan bruno i'm a sailor
i spent uh halftime of my life on the on
the sea
i worn from that jack vaab one time mini
transat race
and with my son matisse we beat a few
records like the mediterranean crossing
record and
english channel crossing record 2.
during my professional sailing time i
hit three times a container and
particularly the last time in 2015
middle of the
atlantic we hit the container in the
night and we break completely the boat
in two pieces
[Music]
we have a factory who can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the boat
[Music]
pollution was not there in the beginning
of the 80s
no plastic at the top of the ocean
when i was young i had the chance to to
see this beautiful oceans with no
pollution
so yes it makes sense for me when i come
back to do the maximum for the to fight
this pollution
[Music]
do stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by the economist vicky price and donnica
mccarthy climate columnist for the
independent and we're going to be
discussing what's been a huge week for
climate the u.n climate report and the
uk's energy security strategy how do
they both affect you
[Music]
well when the pandemic hit we shut the
doors here and uh he became a food bank
for about 18 months when we first shot
it felt a bit silly for us to go home it
felt a bit like running away so we sent
a letter out to the 200. there is people
who lived uh near us and we said that we
were still here and we were willing to
help out and they got in touch asking
for us to fix prescriptions walk their
dogs help with food and then after a
little while the city council heard that
we've done that and as part of their
community hub program they asked 27
organizations of which we were one to
become a kind of network of support and
principally most of us became
food banks and what we discovered during
that time is that people are
unbelievably generous that there is a
huge amount of of people out there
willing to help willing to donate
willing to volunteer but also the
problems that we were facing that we
were inherently weren't caused because
of covid covert had just allowed this
moment of
solution allowed all these people to
have uh
to be able to give up what they normally
do with their time and help out and so
that was a real um uh that was a real
kind of shock to us we weren't aware of
all of that going on in the background
and we we stopped because we ran out of
money and because real life came back
and we needed to get on with the jobs
that we're paid to do that allowed us
the resource to do that but um the the
problems
still face i mean fuel poverty was a
huge problem two years ago and i have no
idea how hard it's going to be now and
and here i'm sat in the theater at the
minute and we we had an event to
celebrate all the community hubs the
community hub program was coming to an
end all those people that had jumped on
and tried to help out the moment of
crisis and we're going back to their to
their everyday jobs and that means that
that support mechanism that was there
which was already a kind of emergency
support mechanism isn't there so we're
dealing with a problem that existed
beforehand that got worse because of
covid that is now getting worse because
of all sorts of pressures and tension
but the resilience isn't there the
people who
who were a bit hit hard in the beginning
they they've just been married for the
last two years and i think that that
collectively as a society we need to
wake up and go we need some
extraordinary measures to try and help
alleviate some of the pressure that
people are under
our mission is to ensure that the people
of whole back have the best possible
cultural life and that is about being
really good at our jobs about making
theater making sure the piano sounds
good and all that stuff that you would
expect but if they're too hungry to
leave their house or they don't know how
to heat the house then they can't come
out and be our audience and it strikes
me that we are as invested in the whole
of our community as we are in our
ability to entertain them
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with the
economist at vicky price and donald
mccarthy climate columnist for the
independent so good to see you both good
evening
so
on monday we had the un's panel of
climate change experts issued their
latest report the u.n secretary general
said investing in new fossil fuels was
moral and economic madness and he called
countries who do so dangerous radicals
then yesterday the uk government
published its new energy strategy and in
it they cleared the way for another
licensing round for oil and gas
companies to drill for more so vicky the
question then is is the government full
of dangerous radicals allowing uh nalsie
oil and gastrin to go ahead
i think it was always known that gas had
a role to play in the energy transition
but what has happened of course uh in
between cop 26 and now is that we have
the war in the ukraine and everyone is
worried about energy security so that
has come up on the agenda and i think
right now it's almost eclipsing um net
zero i'm afraid but what we're talking
about of course is just ensuring that
there is more domestic production which
can meet some of the demands that we
have we would have had to import a lot
of gas anyway and for some time to come
so it's not as if we are doing something
major and and and one that can be if you
like categorize the way that uh
has been done by the un uh but it is a
reaction to the fact that the world
probably still needs quite a lot of gas
prices would have gone up even more if
one didn't have enough
ability to switch to other um gas areas
that can produce sufficiently to make up
for what may be losing as a world from
russia
so it makes sense a thing in the short
term but of course only as a short-term
measure okay i notice you were shaking
your head there but i mean the
government would say it's logical to
replace the oil and gas that we're
giving up from from russia with
domestically produced oil and gas and
they say it's not going to affect our
climate targets but you're shaking your
head what do you think
well to actually have the uk government
just holds the presidency of the united
nations climate conference uh clearly
said any new oil and gas is criminal and
will destroy our hopes of zero so what
the uk government did yesterday is it
gave a message to every country in the
world to gov the words of a government
minister exploit every drop of oil and
gas that you want to
that means suicide for humanity and it's
absolutely disgraceful and in the words
of the un general secretary it is
criminal arson
vicki do you want to pick up on that i
mean we are still presidents of cop26
aren't we and we're trying to persuade
the big polluters of the world to give
up fossil fuels so is this setting a bad
example
i think right now we're in a bind
because of the concern about uh energy
security as i was saying earlier i mean
the same prime minister
went to saudi arabia to try and get more
oil pumped from the ground so it is a
strange environment we're in right now
it's a little bit like reacting in a
certain way when we head covet so it is
an emergency so we need to look at that
as a transition we may be going through
where indeed we may be relying a lot
more on fossil fuels in the short term
or looking at how that security can be
provided by that of course if you look
at the energy strategy it includes loads
of plans in terms of moving to a lot
more
renewables and faster than perhaps have
been assumed originally and with a lot
of money being spent just as you said
earlier in your summary
donaka
well they actually what the government
did yesterday was it announced that it
was moving towards um more more fracking
more north sea oil more nuclear none of
which will bring down our carbon
emissions by 2030. nuclear might deliver
by 2040 2050 but the u.n said clearly
we're in a crisis if we don't cut our
emissions by 50
by 2030. the unipcc report this week
stated that we're looking at a 14
increase when we should have 50 decrease
what
what vicky is expressing there is
traditional treasury thinking the
economics that got us into this mess the
economic the economist that failed for
50 years to prepare for the crisis of
ukraine and to prepare for the crisis of
climate we've got to move away from
these economists that got us into this
lethal existential threat vicky do you
want to defend economists there
well what can i say it was actually an
economist nick sturman to whom i worked
lordster now who did the first climate
change report where he put economics on
top of the science and really got
everyone to realize that we had to act
quite quickly and that the cost of not
doing so
uh and leaving it to later would be
enormous so i think economists have
played a very important very significant
part in in explaining what the science
was implying in terms of why we needed
to act
let's look at the strategy a bit more
closely done what are you going to say
it's the government economist tess
eldest not lord stern it's a government
economist in the treasury have failed us
the last 15 years refused to invest in
in renewables they refused to invest in
insulation they refused to invest in
energy efficiency that means millions of
people in uk homes this winter will be
cold and hungry it's a disgrace and a
failure by our economic system and our
government i'm sorry i have to make a
small correction if i may when nick
stone produced his report he was a
government economist he was head of the
government economic service and that was
his deputy and then i took over from him
jointly with someone else so he was
doing it as a government economist and
he was taken very seriously at the time
and it continues to be taken seriously
uh donald on the subject i'm just going
to move us on to the more broad point
about the the energy security strategy
because the government would say that it
includes a goal of 95 renewables by
2030. i mean that's very much in keeping
with the ipc's cc report isn't it which
says that we have to peak our emissions
in just three years time and then
decline by nearly half by 2030. i mean
doesn't the government strategy fit in
with that
well what's confusing the government's
strategy is it says it will reach us 95
percent renewables but actually it's
putting all the money into nuclear so
how do the two um um square up with each
other nuclear power that nuclear is zero
emissions zero co2 emissions
you cannot build nuclear power stations
by 2030 to bring down carbon emissions
as required it cannot be achieved and so
that's why the government announced
yesterday that nuclear would be safe
and cheap it's actually eyewateringly
expensive even one government minister
that france which was once about the
only country in the world that went down
that route that they the costs are just
mind-boggling you don't want maybe up to
200 billion pounds and it would take 20
years if we invest in in energy storage
solar
and onshore wind we could bring this um
costs down and we could cut our carbon
missions in the next three to five years
that would eliminate needs for any inve
any
in um
sorry imports from russia and and
neighboring european countries vicky do
you think that's a fair point i mean the
obviously this is a broad strategy it's
not just nuclear um as as doneco was
hinting there there's also a lot of
offshore wind but do you think more
could have been done on solar and
onshore wind that would have had quicker
results
i think yes i have to say that i agree
with that um and also i agree that
nuclear may not be the answer it takes a
long time for it to be for anything to
be built and we know full well the cost
com keep going up and then there are
faults and the time scale is really
quite long and we've seen that happen
all across the world and that's a real
real problem but i think if you're
looking at the hundreds of billions if
you like that
have just been mentioned may need to be
spent on nuclear and some i know over a
period of time we could certainly have
spent a lot more on energy efficiency
and one of the gaps that we still have
is the whole insulation uh what happens
at a domestic front given that we have
such an old housing stock so i think in
terms of looking at where the emphasis
is
in this energy
strategy i think it's the wrong way i
don't have anything against nuclear and
we know that the taxonomy overall we
know that the taxonomy that the eu has
produced now includes nuclear and gas as
part of clean and inverted commerce that
i know that not everyone agrees with but
that's how the world is moving so
nuclear may well play a part but i think
in terms of speed uh doing more and
renewables would have been considerably
better all on energy efficiency and or
rather on energy efficiency a quick word
on energy efficiency dona i imagine you
agree with vicki i've heard a lot of
people saying that was a miss from this
strategy are you one of them
absolutely i mean thankfully there's
significant consensus everywhere except
maybe in government and in the major
papers that this is the right thing to
do there's around 9 million people which
had their homes insulated by now the
government hadn't slashed the
installation program in 2012 and
yesterday the chance refused to put a
penny more into that program just
mind-boggling he's flown off to
california and left people high and dry
in the uk with expensive bills
yesterday's program will not reduce
bills by one penny when he could have
invested in onshore wind in insulation
for homes and storage and that would
bring people's bills down and that's
what we need bring the pigs
the bills down and cut carbon emissions
a win-win okay and very very briefly
each of you how quickly are we going to
see cheaper bills from greener sources
vicky very briefly
well greener sources are cheaper i have
to admit to that
but it's going to take quite some time
and what i worry about is that in the
meantime with bills being so high people
may be turned off
uh sort of net zero if you like and and
really care much much more at anything
including whether it's gas or oil or any
way of getting more uh and cheaper
energy
in order for this cost of living crisis
to be over faster so i'm work i worry
frankly about it do you have the same
concerns that climate concerns will go
off people's agenda because they're more
worried about affordability
well i think actually what's really
interesting now compared to 10 years ago
is affordability and cutting carbon are
on the same page it's actually fossil
fuels and nuclear are are wide
wateringly expensive and don't address
the climate change fast enough so we're
we should be in a win-win that's what's
mind-boggling about what the chancellor
is doing he could have cut bills and cut
carbon emissions he's done the opposite
okay i'm wrapping him up because we're
out of time but donna kurt and vicky
very good to see you both interesting to
hear your views thank you both
so thanks for watching we're out of time
but i'll see you next time
[Music]
you